das habe ich so noch nie erlebt da
jauchzen tesla fahrer hemmungslos in die
kamera und das netz wird geflutet mit
videos aus auto cockpits ihnen macht hat
seinen nächsten coup gelandet die erste
beta für volles autonomes fahren ist
veröffentlicht worden und die ersten
fahrer posten videos die das system
hands on oder besser hands aufzeigen
warum jetzt eine neue epoche anbricht
klicks um 20 user gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
teslas haben in jeder hinsicht ein
absolut revolutionäres fahrzeugkonzept
teslas sind nicht nur einfach
elektroautos sondern fahrende
innovationsträger was die konkurrenz
tatsächlich in angst und schrecken
versetzt ist die computertechnik in
einem tesla statt 80 bis 100
steuergeräte für jede einzelne
funktionen wie klimaanlage esp
fensterheber scheibenwischer abs und so
weiter und so fort haben tesla nur ein
einziges einen hochleistungs computer
der alles zentral steuert das ist so
revolutionär dass der kabelbaum in einem
tesla demnächst von einem roboter
verlegt werden kann das ist drin mich
wirklich eine sensation die kabel die
sind dann nicht mehr wem model s 3
kilometer lang sondern 100 meter in
einem vw bmw oder mercedes wäre das
undenkbar
die beschleunigung der fahrzeuge ist
atemberaubend selbst in der einfachsten
version beschleunigt das model 3 in 5,6
sekunden auf 100 kilometer pro stunde
die fahrzeuge verfügen über acht kameras
um den verkehr zu beobachten und darauf
zu reagieren und in verbindung mit dem
hochleistungsrechner wird bisher für
unmöglich gehaltenes wohl möglich werden
wie sich jetzt in diesen tagen
herausstellt und nicht zuletzt hat
deshalb das große problem des
elektroantriebs gelöst was die
konventionellen autobauer noch nicht mal
erkannt hatten das batteriemanagement
tesla hat es quasi erfunden
tesla hat sich als einziger
autohersteller
dazu gemacht und sie dann auch in die
tat umgesetzt wie batterien behandelt
werden müssen damit sie in dem
temperaturbereich arbeiten denen die
batterie hersteller vorgegeben haben
deshalb baute als erstes ein kühl und
heizsystem in die wagen ein und konnte
so zum ersten mal zwei dinge
gewährleisten die reichweite sinkt bei
kälte nicht mehr dramatisch bis zur
unbrauchbarkeit und zweitens halten die
batterien durch diese behandlung
entscheidend länger nämlich verglichen
mit einem verbrenner mehrere auto leben
und mit all diesen innovationen sind
teslas mehr als autos sind
technologieträger und einen blick in die
zukunft sie verändern unsere sicht auf
die welt und nicht nur in der realität
wenn irgendein sportwagen auf der
autobahn dicht auffährt und man im tesla
das gaspedal antippt wird man sich
wundern warum die anderen autos im
rückspiegel den rückwärtsgang einlegen
ein tesla ist tatsächlich so als würde
man in einem paralleluniversum aufwachen
und jetzt wird dieses gefühl noch
stärker denn was besser da als update
over dr
gerade zugänglich gemacht hat ist
schlicht und ergreifend spektakulär
das ist wirklich ein wenig skurril weil
zwei tesla fahrer offensichtlich angst
haben die geheimhaltungsvereinbarung mit
tesla zu brechen zeigen sie nicht das
system sondern ihre reaktion darauf
und die ist wirklich lustig ich fahre ja
selbst ein model s und ich kann mir sehr
genau vorstellen was da gerade passiert
plötzlich hat das auto vollkommen neue
fähigkeiten und kann dinge die niemand
vorher für möglich gehalten hat
insbesondere nicht die fachwelt wer
heute einen tesla kauft und die option
volles potenzial für autonomes fahren
mit bestellt der bekommt ein fahrzeug
das bereits heute über einige sehr
bemerkenswerten fähigkeiten verfügt zwar
muss in deutschland der fahne jederzeit
in der lage seien die kontrolle zu
übernehmen aber ein solches elektroauto
kann nahezu selbstständig auf der
autobahn von a nach b fahren sprich
lediglich spur wechseln müssen von hand
bestätigt werden das fahrzeug führt sie
dann aber selbstständig aus in der stadt
hält ein so ausgestatteter tester
selbstständig an ampeln und fährt nach
bestätigung wieder los allerdings können
die wagen weder selbstständig abbiegen
noch die spur wechseln usw
das erlebnis ist aber schon ziemlich
spektakulär aber noch sehr
beschränkt mit dem update 20 20.40 punkt
8.10 hat sich das jetzt grundlegend
geändert bisher lief diese software auf
den fahrzeugen im hintergrund im
sogenannten shadow modus das heißt sie
griff überhaupt nicht ein und war auch
im cockpit gar nicht zugänglich aber
lernte bei jedem gefahrenen kilometer im
hintergrund von abertausenden teslas
denn das ist der quantensprung von tesla
mit hunderttausenden autos sammelt der
energiekonzern ständig aber und
abermillionen daten um seine systeme zu
trainieren und in der
entwicklungsabteilung sitzen hunderte
fachleute die nichts anderes machen als
die videos zu labeln sprich wenn die
fahnen ihr einverständnis gegeben haben
werden die aufnahmen der acht kameras zu
tesla übermittelt und dort analysiert
die künstliche intelligenz hinter dem
system muss lernen was was ist ist das
ein fahrrad das ganz normal gefahren
wird ist es auf einem gepäckträger
montiert wird es geschoben und so weiter
jede möglichkeit muss die software
lernen und wenn sie dann jeweils gut
vorbereitet ist dann lernt sie von
selbst weiter und jetzt hat sie offenbar
so viel gelernt dass ihnen must see
freigegeben hat noch vor wenigen wochen
hat sie auf seiner eigenen
pendlerstrecke noch drei fehler gemacht
bei denen musk eingreifen musste aber
diese situation hat sie jetzt gemeistert
und jetzt soll das system weiter lernen
nur sehr wenige tesla konnten die
version 2.0 20.40 punkt 8.10
installieren in den einschlägigen
verzeichnis in denen aufgelistet ist wer
wann welche software installiert hat ist
sogar nur ein einziges modell 3 zu
finden stand 23 zehnter 2020 12 uhr
mittags es dürften aber schon bereits
wohl einige dutzend seien allerdings
kommt das update rund ein jahr später
als es ihnen mast angekündigt hatte der
grund die ursprüngliche software
funktionierte nicht für skeptiker ein
grundmaß aussage anzuzweifeln dass das
system überhaupt jemals funktionieren
würde
denn alle konkurrenten setzen auf
zahlreiche sensoren unter anderem lieder
einem system zur abstands und
geschwindigkeitsmessung mit
laserstrahlen macht hält das für
überflüssigen quatsch und ist davon
überzeugt lediglich mit kameras und
radar die umgebung der fahrzeuge
ausreichend zu erfassen und der rollout
dieser beta weise
es scheint ihm recht zu geben sie
basiert jetzt auf der dreidimensionalen
erfassung aller objekte und wurde
komplett neu geschrieben um den
autopiloten endlich zum funktionieren zu
bringen
die fahrenden sind begeistert und von
großen fehlern wie den phantom bremsung
beim bisherigen system wird auch nicht
berichtet denn das war ein großes
problem der bisherigen software das
inzwischen behoben worden sein soll
aktiviert man nämlich den tempomat dann
wird auch immer die abstands funktion
des model s aktiviert dabei wählt man
den abstand manuell am hebel für den
tempomaten und den autopiloten
wenn man den hebel einmal zu sich zieht
dann wird der tempomat aktiviert und
beim doppel zog aktiviert sich der
autopilot der zum einen die spur hält
und zum anderen nach betätigen des
blinkers automatisch die spur wechselt
und wenn man die automatische navigation
gewählt hat auch selbstständig
ausfahrten inklusive blinken und
abfahren nimmt dann muss man selbst nach
einigen hundert metern das steuer
übernehmen so weit so gut doch zuweilen
wird das system komplett außerplanmäßig
selbst aktiv und bremst ziemlich stark
also zumindest bisher
das ist keine vollbremsung aber eine
sehr starke verzögerung mit der im
zweifel fahrzeuge hinter einem nicht
rechnen auffahrunfälle drohnen das kann
im fließenden verkehr passieren oder
auch komplett freier bahn vor einem wo
sich überhaupt kein hindernis befindet
also genau der seltene fall in dem
derjenige haftet der vorne bremst das
wäre dann dumm gebremst das scheint also
vom tisch zu sein und die tesla tvd test
erfahren und fahrer auch genannt werden
sind absolut begeistert das ist auch
kein wunder was soll jetzt dokumentiert
wird ist absolut mind blowing zum einen
zeigt das display jetzt eine vollkommen
neue ansicht mass karte ja ein 4d system
angekündigt das system soll nicht nur
den raum erfassen sondern eben auch
zeitliche abläufe um abzuschätzen wann
welches objekt in der zukunft wohl sein
könnte um kollisionen zu vermeiden
aus den acht kamera winkeln wird die
situation aus der vogelperspektive
dreidimensional erfasst und somit ein
beeindruckendes abbild der realen
situation generiert jetzt sind plötzlich
vollkommen neue dinge möglich das system
kann das fahrzeug jetzt in einen
kreisverkehr steuer und wieder heraus
mit der alten software war das unmöglich
das konnte sie einfach nicht endlich
kann links in den verkehr zügig
abgebogen werden das system bewährt sich
keine bestätigung vom fahrer mehr
sondern kann vollkommen autonom den
gesamten verkehr erfassen und darauf
reagieren es weicht fahrzeugen aus hält
an ampeln und fährt ohne zutun los und
so weiter und so fort mal wieder hat
ihren maske alle skeptiker lügen
gestraft und unmögliches möglich gemacht
allerdings warentest jetzt noch
eindringlicher vor der verwendung als
schon beim bisherigen system weil diese
version noch und kalkuliert reagieren
kann was nur durch aufmerksames fahren
verhindert werden kann so die release
notes das risiko wird als extrem hoch
eingeschätzt dass sich fahrende schon
bei dieser beta version zu 100 prozent
darauf verlassen was tödlich sein kann
aber als erprobter tesla fahrer oder als
fahrerin kennt man das ja vom alten
system
man musste auf phantom beim sondern eben
vorbereitet sein und sie schnell
abbrechen in baustellen folgte das
fahrzeug gerne auch mal den falschen
markierung wem sein leben lieb ist der
weiß dass man solchen systemen noch
nicht 100 prozent vertrauen kann und das
auch nicht darf in deutschland soll
autonomes fahren ab 2022 erlaubt sein
allerdings muss bis dahin auch ein
tempolimit er denn fahrzeuge die von
hinten mit 250 run brettern kann kein
system erfassen auf jeden fall hat muss
mit diesem system jetzt den weg zu dem
tesla robo taxis frei gemacht jede und
jeder kann in der zukunft seinen tesla
als robo taxi betreiben und somit geld
verdienen die software wird dann so
erweitert dass man zum einen zum
beispiel familienmitglieder hinzufügen
kann die dann mit ihrem smartphone die
fahrzeuge öffnen können aber man kann
das fahrzeug auch wenn man es nicht
braucht als robo taxi betreiben und
jeder kann sich dann von einem privaten
tesla chauffieren lassen und die
besitzer und besitzerinnen verdienen
dabei auch noch geld mit ihren testlauf
das taxi netzwerk inklusive flotte ist
bei einem tesla schon mit eingebaut und
mit dem heutigen tag wird diese
perspektive jetzt schon viel konkreter
und noch mehr revolutionäre technik gibt
es bei tesla die batterie revolution
tesla batterie kommt 2022 anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal klicks und salz im future
bis dann
bleibt dran